today is adrian's last day um adrian's
been here since january adrian has
inspired me
it's 1 10 and i got up until 2 o'clock
to get
what usually would take 4 hours
no i'd say more like 45 minutes to 20.
yeah
the usual
[Applause]
[Music]
cool
sweet
setting up knocking them down
[Applause]
hi i'm making a flicker box so you can
do muzzle flash lighting in real life
high powered light with a momentary on
off button and just tap it every time
you want to flash
and it flashes and in the future it'd be
cool to hook it up to some sort of
sound sensitive trigger like maybe with
an arduino or something like that and
have it so anytime you pull a trigger on
a gas pistol the loud bang in the gas
pistol
makes the light flash for now we're
starting simple got a high-powered light
led light the kind that would sit on the
top of like a jeep v-lock battery plate
we have a lot of v-lock batteries i got
a momentary on off switch those three
things together will make my life work
don't know what you're making but i'm
really excited no this is road rash i
felt my one wheel at 15 miles an hour i
had all my pads my elbow pads on pads
work wear them
[Music]
this is distressing it's given a dust
and dirt look to it it also helps bring
down some of the green that got on when
i wasn't very careful
same color that we use to prime so it'll
give that damage it'll come out a little
more and then we paint
yeah it looks good here and then there
imagine if you're looking at a character
who's just completely clean
you'll assume that he's been through
nothing yeah whereas if you look at a
character who is completely covered in
dirt blood and charred marks and you
know you would imagine that he's been
through some [ __ ] people wearing new
clothes every day this is their favorite
shirt it's their favorite they're
wearing it even if it's dirty uh good
job jared this looks awesome
all right so i finished assembling the
light this is an led light that would go
on top of like a truck for off-roading
this is a v-lock battery plate but now
into the lock battery like so take for
example this anton bauer v-mount lock it
mount it right on the v-lock plate and
then you can run output from the power
to whatever you want i then wire those
wires from the v-mount up to the light
the wire goes through this little
momentary on off switch so this switch
is always off until i push it down and
then it's on i let go it goes back to
off and i just simply mounted the light
this little wooden plank these bolts and
then screw the v-lock plate on this
little wooden plank very simple build
battery momentary on off switch within
the connection to the light and the
light the light that can take the input
range of the battery so this should work
so let's try it out
okay battery's mounted
[Music]
on the truth
[Music]
it works
very bright as you know so the hot spot
in the middle so this will actually
shine outside with the sun i can hold it
on or make it quick
all right let's get all the lights in
here
the reason i have this button as opposed
to a strobe is that if the light goes
too fast uh you get the rolling shutter
artifacts so you can keep it on long
enough for the entire frame to see it so
when you're doing your gunshot effects
you know
muzzle flashes if we won't get like half
of a frame getting the light you'll get
the whole frame so nico has an awesome
invention
now when we add muzzle flashes it's
going to have a sense of realism all
right aim your gun three two one
bang bang bang bang
real quick christian that's you
time for
my special shot
this patch do you copy
located the target and in pursuit copy
we got a group of knights in the room
wait five minutes
negative you should be dead in five
minutes right michael bay pushes his
face into the monitor so why don't you
over here we have matt and i've rigged
up our
fabric led light which is basically just
a soft box but very flat
uh on a
light stand which we're using like a
boom pole and he's
wearing the battery on his belt and
holding it above and it's been great
because we basically have a really soft
sourcing light above the actor at all
times no heavy heavy equipment no
sandbags no worrying about [ __ ] falling
over on people
all i gotta worry about is matt and his
slippery fingers so matt you're gonna
basically check yourself in here
you're gonna kind of follow him and once
he gets about here let him like stay
still and let him leave the light okay
basically he's finishing his lineup
ready
and rehearsal action
thank you
safety here's the deal when you're
lining up shots on the camera you got to
pull focus autofocus sucks so you gotta
do it by hand you either gotta have
somebody with their hands on the camera
you get a really expensive rig a little
motor next to the lens that will pull
focus for you and that's hooked up to
somebody who's operating a little wheel
more gear on your camera it's another
power draw from the battery a huge
hassle is the kind of thing you only see
in the film industry these lenses have
focus motors built into them that's
super cool that can save you a ton of
time on this red i can actually control
focus with this little wheel and that's
really neat but you know even cooler is
to somehow be able to pull focus
wirelessly to the camera without any
gear any bars any motors any kits
without making this camera heavier
without pulling more juice from the
battery so it dies sooner i got a plan
for that red cameras have wi-fi built
into them and there's an app out there
called full control and this app lets me
control all the settings here it is this
is my camera settings i can change my
iso and i can change my f-stop that's
good my shutter the extra cool thing
about this put this lens into all the
focus mode i can go here
and i can pull focus and pull focus this
helmet here
helmet
to iron man
to the weird mannequin wearing the wig
in the middle problem is it would
disconnect once in a while i don't know
it's the lenses or the app or what
that's what i'm going to do an
experiment on right now to find out i'm
just going to stress test this i'm going
to do it as long as i can until it stops
working
this is all an elaborate set up for me
to advertise skillshare to you
i've sponsored numerous videos in the
past we were lucky enough to have them
sponsor this one skillshare is an online
learning community made up of thousands
of high quality videos from a bunch of
different artists or businessmen
entrepreneurs basically people trying to
teach you what you need to know i'm
going to talk to you about fine art we
get a lot of questions like hey should i
go to film school the thing is sam and i
studied fine art in college and i found
that to be actually one of the most
useful degrees that you could have
possibly gotten back when we started
corridor digital we were doing vfx for
hire people would hire us out do little
projects here and there when we do
visual effects for ourselves we would
apply all our knowledge from the fine
art classes to visual effects for
example one of the things they teach you
pay attention to where your eye moves i
likes to move to bright objects in the
room like that or to somebody's face
especially their eyes what you're
definitely not paying attention to is
this black pole or that gray square
you're paying attention to this you're
paying attention to me your eye might go
there eventually but not right away so
when you're doing visual effects on a
shot and there's a bright explosion in
the right corner and there's the ground
that's black in the left corner and you
have a little error a little mask or
some problem tracking area in that
little black shadow in the lower left
corner we don't worry about it when we
do visual effects the chord channel
because you will never see it you will
always be looking at the bright
explosion but when you do visual effects
for higher
they analyze that pixel by pixel they go
through they find every single flock
because they don't watch it like the
audience does they watch it because they
spend money and they gotta get their
dollars worth every pixel and it's
infuriating if you can apply the
principles of fine art to your life you
can save yourself a lot of time and a
lot of money i want to talk about one of
the lessons or one of the tutorials on
skillshare where they talk about
composition and art what it means to
have value shapes contrast lines
lighting rule of thirds balance all that
kind of stuff and you know what the
class is for people who are painting but
it doesn't matter if you're painting or
not you can apply it to anything you can
literally apply it to your word
documents you can apply it to your
furniture layout in your house that's
how universal this stuff is i have lost
connection
oh and i got it back it's a little jumpy
just definitely not very smooth maybe
it's software and hardware
you're right
it's probably both you know that texture
applies to a lot of things too that's
how focus works soft focus is soft
texture hard focus is a sharp texture
that draws your eye from one to the
other creates contrast which is visually
pleasing and helps you make a better
frame all these lessons can be yours by
signing up for skillshare premium
membership will give you access free
access to all the classes from all these
various experts and people that have
made these lessons how do you sign up
for all these classes skl.sh slash
quarter crew 2 gets you the first two
months for free skl that sh slash
quarter crew two guess it's like skill
share but really abbreviated skilled
sure slash quarter crew
how much does it cost an annual
membership costs less than ten dollars a
month besides you get two months free to
figure it out it's cheaper than youtube
red cheer the netflix
thanks dog yeah dude
urban zelda on a on a hot roof here guys
it's like a hundred and
something
[Music]
nope
different coffee
more iq for less
but i love trim
you're like that jurassic park dinosaur
we out here
trying to keep cool
get the shade on our bodies
i only have about three to three and a
half hours to film this whole scene in
front of you
today we're filming urban zelda day four
the final showdown we're up on the roof
and it's really sunny up here we've got
about four pages of dialogue to shoot
and we've got about three hours to do it
so let's get after it i'm a grip today
[Music]
get that silk sale on sale time i got it
on sales some sale on sale someone got a
16 on sale it's less when's the last
time you had a silk sale on sale from a
sales sign
say
yeah beautiful do i must say i got a
sailing son i'm on a warship kind of
save me so you kind of sell me son i got
the sales up son with the sale of the
clothes and the sale up and the silks
and the giants
he's only got an hour left never seen
him
quite have such the amount of focus that
he has right now he's like usually he'll
look at a shot we'll get the frame up
and then he'll right before he wants to
roll he'll look at it and make
adjustments to the frame like finally
final adjustments to lighting and stuff
today
our boy's burning right through shots
he's like okay you this that that and so
far
i think he's doing a good job
oh man
ready for this ready for this yeah let's
do it
when you find out
the hand soap at the restaurant is
shrimp flavor
when you get shrimp isn't it when you
get shrimp appetizers
it's going man i'm just like
i'm like yeah well not yet we still have
a good two hours
yeah an hour two yeah 9 30 9 30.
you're chilling man it's a cool hat you
got there thanks carmichael it's like a
vietnamese screaming hat
how much sunlight do we have left let's
say we got about an hour of sun and we
got about an hour shooting
so uh this week is actually going to be
my last week for a while here at
corridor you know can come as bad news
for those of you who enjoyed what i've
been doing or good for those of you
not so happy with what i've been
creating i really enjoy working here i'm
sure you guys are probably thinking now
what's the reason was he fired or did he
quit and it's nothing like jake
punch checking though it's nothing like
that everyone here i love working with
everyone here everyone got along it's
more due to outside life circumstances
um that i don't necessarily want to get
into you know i have the hopes to return
sometime early 2019. that's currently my
goal he has an ability to see it all the
way through that's a true filmmaker
ability and i respect that about it
while there's certainly a little
friction here and there adrian has
inspired me bumps and bruises broke his
collarbone i was hacking the story
i'll miss you
but
we've also been shooting together for a
couple years so i'm sure it's going to
keep going on
thanks for sticking around adrian it's
been a ton of fun i look forward to more
in the future at some point if you
haven't yet go check out urban zelda
it's the last thing he's directed for
the horror channel never give up on your
dreams because if you really are truly
passionate about something
that passion will be enough fuel to take
you through your voyage that even when
you hit these roadblocks you will be
able to persevere personally i've ran
into so many roadblocks on this
filmmaking journey if i wasn't as
passionate and i didn't love this as
much as i do i would have given up a
long time ago so just
keep with it man and for those who are
not filmmakers
keep watching these videos because what
they do here is amazing i don't really
see it on too many other youtube
channels that's why i wanted to work
here so
make sure you subscribe
hit that bell button so you know when
you know they're pumping out new videos
and i hope to see you sometime in 2019